split
hello everyone hello everyone welcome to
today's live broadcast emerging
applications in preclinical micro CT
imaging I am Christina jewel of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
PerkinElmer PerkinElmer is a global
leader focused on improving the health
and safety of people and the environment
they're dedicated team of 8,000
employees worldwide are passionate about
providing customers with an unmatched
experience as they help solve critical
issues in human and environmental health
PerkinElmer innovative detection imaging
informatics and service capabilities
combined with the deep market knowledge
and expertise help customers gain
greater insights into their science to
better protect our environment our food
supply and the health for our families
for more information please visit www
mp4 we begin just a couple of important
announcement this webcast is designed to
be interactive and we encourage you to
ask questions during the event you could
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
Q&A button lower left I would like to
now introduce today's speakers we have
two speakers today Krista mophie and dr.
Dale rochefort speaking
first today will be Chris demo see
Christopher demo see is the senior staff
officer imaging scientist and manager of
the Columbia University small animal
imaging shared resource at the Herbert
Irving Comprehensive Cancer Center after
receiving his bachelors from fairleigh
dickinson university in 2001 Kristen OC
started working at the Garden State
Cancer Center and the center for
molecular medicine and immunology he
then moved to I'm clone systems and then
eli lilly and company focusing on
preclinical experimental therapeutics
and their monoclonal antibody platforms
he has also worked as part of the teams
that brought a number of breakthrough
drugs to market specifically erbitux and
ceramic in his current role at columbia
team enters the next generations of
research scientists throughout the
Herbert Irving Comprehensive Cancer
Center teaching the benefits of
non-invasive imaging like mi CT
ultrasound and optical for their ongoing
longitudinal imaging studies I will now
turn it over to Chris for his
presentation good morning everybody but
as Christy said my name is Krista Murphy
and I'm going to discuss today we're
going to work on PDA katek see so a PA
is a dot still adding a pancreatic
ductal adenocarcinoma so we're going to
look at pancreatic tumors specifically
how are our perkinelmer quantum effects
microct is being utilized in the
research and study of some of the
effects of these kids so as Chris is
saying i work at the columbia university
a small animal imaging shared resource
we are core facility for columbia
university medical center and we
research many many preclinical cancer
treatments we also do diabetic work
cardiology worth neuroscience as well we
are we have thi field magnetic resonance
imager
topic the quantum effects micro-ct the
ibis optical imaging system and
ultrasound and we're actually getting a
text distance into and as I said we
located at Columbia University Medical
Center in New York Presbyterian Hospital
here in New York so just to show our our
specific perkinelmer quantum effects
microct is located on the animal
facility here at the urban urban
Comprehensive Cancer Center and needing
lysing it for a little over two years
now and some of the things that we do
just to give you a quick run-through of
those different modalities and
methodologies that we have available are
very very well reflect it's not just as
long as I said so we do a lot of soft
tissue imaging with with Markham and in
this case we're looking at some lung
tissue images what was done with this
specific study was one of our
investigators was working on
inflammation and infection of the lungs
from bacteria so you'll see that the
right lung versus elect long has a very
different structure and actual actually
it's kind of clogged up with lots of
information so that's one of the things
that what about our CIS are doing here
another thing is multimodal mobile
imaging so we also have as I said before
the Ibis term optical imaging system and
the next thing is we do a lot of
co-registration with the micro CT here
and the iris optical system we're in a
lot of cases we are looking at let's say
lung capacity and we were able to locate
them to stir them within some of our
studies that are the only logic to GUI
as you can see here there's also bone
met for one of the studies that we've
done I one of the other things that
we've done is actual full lung volumes
where is this is actually an image from
one of our one of our studies where we
looked at radiation treatments on the
lungs and how they affect
a long structure and health over time
that's there's many many things that you
can do with RCC again as pretty much
everybody knows there's a lot of
excellent uses for the CT with the bone
structure and density and looking at the
microvasculature in micro areas of the
phone one of the great things and things
that I actually focus on is using doing
a pancreatic imaging so one of the
things we've done in the past is to use
nanoparticles to see the blood vessel
structure of the mouse and in many cases
we were able to actually see where the
pancreatic tumor in this one was a very
large one so we used it as a good
example where there's less vasculature
within the actual tumor so there's
mistaking as you can see using FTP we're
also looking at using nanoparticles to
follow longitudinally liver metastases
and this is an example of how we can see
the liver mess that existed within a
mouse that has obviously liver
adolescent also something doing a lot
with the diabetes center actually is
measuring liver steatosis so we just
this is just an example of the same for
me that we had taken ex vivo we're on
the left you'll see a healthy liver
where you were able to get gating of
certain thresholds to see the the fat
around the liver and on the right you'll
see a very old you smell that actually
has genetic abnormalities cause liver
steatosis which is the fattening of the
liver they could see that there is a
much greater amount of assess and the
other so I'm going to move on to what
we're I'm going to talk about today
which is capilla so one of the things
that we've worked on here at Columbia is
pancreatic cancer pancreatic cancers is
devastating disease that has a horrible
mortality rate and one of the thing
that happens with pancreatic cancer is
cancer Sophia cachexia which is a
complex metabolic syndrome which is
characterized by the loss of the muscle
or without the loss of fat so you'll see
muscle wasting within the bodies of the
patients that happens disease and you
cannot restrict nutritionally it has a
poor prognosis for for the patients at
the point at which they are diagnosed
with the texting and frankly from at
risk over the past few years there is
really no known pathway and primary
factors that for cachexia and health how
it's really done and how its treated so
we'll work on finding the factors that
cause the muscle thing and again it's
been going on for a long time and it
will probably continue for a long time
stuff so some of the implications of
cancer-associated cachexia as i said
before depriest survival reduced
response to chemotherapeutic and reduce
way of life due to the functional
physiological effects of basically your
muscles makes me wet it's closely
related to many other symptoms answer
including anorexic recipe long weight
loss is the incidence of cancer
associated exact text is very high in
gastric filming malignancies and why
we're studying it especially high in
Thank You Erica immigrated up to eighty
percent of the people that have advanced
pancreatic cancers you come down with
cancer associated one of the things that
we're hypothesizing is 10x is related to
drivers within each tumor and stromal
environment and are secreted there are
secreted and circulating signal so one
of the things we would like to find and
what we've been working on is how to
actually see the beginning of cachexia
with within a preclinical research and
how to then tests blood tests or the
tissues to see if there are factors that
are going force so first we have to
identify to k
okay so I work with McKenna olive lab
here at Columbia University and one of
the things they focus on pancreatic
ductal adenocarcinoma they have a
genetically engineered kpc mouse model
which is clinically relevant to a
pancreatic ductal and the costumes and
also the mice here I received cancer
received well they are diagnosed with
cancer associated cachexia once the PDAs
are present within the animal they run a
mouse hospital that Mouse hospital is it
is an amazing facilities here at
Columbia they recreate all the aspects
of the clinical trial using mouse model
cancers so what they do is the model
itself is spontaneous
I test the animals
ultra to make sure that they see the
beginning
life it be enrolled in a phase one or
phase two trial and they recapitulate
the things as close how do we measure
cachexia they're all actually measure to
clear a path one of them is the CM x-ray
absorptiometry the problem that we have
run into as in doing the studies that we
would like to do is that it's not
possible to delay the dose of x the dose
of x rays is so high that it's a
terminal procedure so it's only can be
done at the end of the study and if we
want to follow along the the mug to
measure the volume of muscle within an
animal that's not possible to obviously
be using this so what we have is using
the CT that the quantum effects micra CT
that we have here to actually do
longitudinal studies because some of the
chain one of the one of the great prose
of the micro CT is the lack of the high
dose of x-ray so we were doing some
research and we showed that CTS can be
used in human to then correlate to the
dexter measurements for for lean body
mass or muscle mass as you would say so
what people have done in humans is to
actually show that if you take a single
slice of the CT at the third lumbar your
effect measurement using a functional
quantification functionally question
actually equal the total body frame at
and total body fat mass of that patient
the question that we ran into is okay so
we have an idea of an equation that we
can start with our question is how do we
correlate this or how do we transfer
this to Mike so obviously human and
Mike's are different in scale if not
everything else so we have to find an
actual way to make that equation work
for animals so in our research one of
the things that we did was specifically
from a paper by research look back is
well this is actually talking about the
human so how can we recapitulate this in
a human setting or in a mouse study we
found a paper in sensors in 2015 that
they correlated CT to actually doing
quantitative and mr lean mass method so
from here we were able to actually have
a starting point equation life which was
axe or a really really great place to
begin and you're able to refine and
optimize our equation that we will use
both in the third one bar of a mouse
getting a single slice instead of
antibody and being able to then take
that the air of the muscle around the
spinal cord and actually also including
the the abdominal wall which i will get
to later to that there's an interesting
story with that and then we were able to
then you pop that into the equation and
show that we are very well correlated
with the actual moon a sithean Oh using
the decks biscuit so some of the some of
the examples of our procedures using the
perimeter quantum effects are shown here
what we tend to do is look at the third
one bar circle filling here and I'm
going to just wrap wrap around here do
my best to show you what the area around
the spinal cord that would be muscle and
also the area around the abdominal wall
here are the little drew just to give
you an example that's barriers that we
would be focusing on short fat fruit
there is a lean muscle met at the body
of the map
one of the two do is obviously we need
to do the image processing so some of
the things that not only are looking at
looking a mess we're also looking at the
subcutaneous fat Matt one of the great
things about the quantum effects is
extremely easy to analyze the fat mass
for subsequent and visceral fat mass
within the body of the animal advocacy
here there's SOPs and proper ways to go
about doing this that are pretty
prevalent in making people would know
how to do it it's pretty straightforward
classif forget your fat fat mattress
whole body of an animal so for imaging
the leading slices is a little bit
different because you have to make sure
that you get rid of all of the different
other tissues make sure that they don't
connect and add into your area so one of
the things that we do is we create edge
strengthened and walls within the body
of them animal allows us to then use
some automated fifties to get the areas
that we are looking so when we image a
single slice for the lean mass of an
animal it tends to look like this is
actually one of the more difficult
animals that we had to use because there
was not a lot of contrast and I won't
explain why but just wanted to give you
an example that was probably a little
bit like this open maybe one what we
would do is we would create a wall
around the area of the muscle within the
spinal cord we would then through
thresholding to get the area within of
the muscle mass we would eliminate the
spinal cord itself and we were just
showing that we added that in with the
subcutaneous and visceral fat mass
within its not so then we simply go and
then do in volume analysis use a leaf
specifically used analyze pro here at
Columbia and there's many different
analysis programs that are available
they all have their fur they all have
their cons this is just the one that we
sell so you would get an area or that
that muscle mass and then popular the
equation that we
we've worked on here and we're able to
get a very well correlated number of the
lean fat marbling muscle mass of the
animal as a whole but one of the first
things we ran into was our first run of
data was a little off and we noticed
when you look at it let's say when you
look at this image here that we are not
including the muscle of the abdominal
wall which I'm drawing kind of a line
with in here and it may not look like
it's a large amount of volume but it was
so what we went back and recalculated
and added in the muscle wall here as you
can see as an example it's actually very
easy to do there was plenty of contrast
because it was with the CT and we didn't
actually he's a contrast agent I should
say with these Mike's just contrast of
the tissues compared to the surrounding
tissue and we were able to then add that
into the the image and calculate the
volume including that area and we went
in go ahead and did some reaches
region-of-interest qualifications
showing that we're even adding in the
abdominal wall of the animal into the
lean muscle mass quantification one of
the things and those kind of things
before is we ran into an issue with
exciting mix so hemorrhagic societies is
also a prognosis and unfortunate
prognosis of pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma where the adoptive in
will be filled with some bloody fluid
the problem is obviously blood is filled
with iodine or not I iron I should take
season and it adds to a little bit of
causes a little bit of a problem with
imaging so one of the first things we
tried was adding in failing G the
abdominal cavity that was kind of really
not effective as you see by the middle
middle image so what we actually did was
we added a contrast agent to the
abdominal cavity food by an
intraperitoneal injection
and that actually helped tremendously to
show us the different organs that you
can see throughout the slice we were
able to find a slice with in the third
lumbars of the majority of the animals
where we were able to easily delineate
what was the muscle in the abdominal
wall versus the surrounding tissues so
there are ways to actually get past
these little turtles that you run into
the cage but just to sum up what we're
currently doing right now we have over
80 animals that we've run through this
this protocol improvements can be made
such as a [ __ ] ease running into an
optimizing way to image those animals
having abdominal wall identification
would be a little bit better if there's
a little bit of each error in drawing up
the walls in the areas that we would be
energy however the coalition that we've
come up with to doing the DEXA scans at
the end of the study with with the
measurements of the muscle mass of the
animal is fair we still have a couple
outliers at which trying to figure out
why but it's obviously an ongoing path
okay is a damaging to do state that
needs more investigation and really is
not a good model that exists currently
and we're hoping that we can show a way
to take a look at cachexia
longitudinally versus just waiting for
the physiological to show up which we
believe we have found this accurately
accurate clinically relevant model and a
method to longitudinally measure the
cancer associated detects it in a crude
clinical investigation and it hopefully
will allow us to further delve into the
reasons and characteristics of the
development of cancer-associated
effective in patients in humans and in
our research I would just like to thank
some of the people that I've worked with
here dr. Paul o'buck Dean Wilson could
see the sastra
with the director of the small animal
imaging shared resource here along the
university dr kennel thank you very much
thank you Chris our next speaker is dr.
Dale Rochefort dr. Gail Rochefort is a
professor at the dental school faculty
Paris discard a university professors
bro shirt joined the EA 2496 oral facial
pathologies imaging and bio serapis in
2013 in his current role he is
responsible for managing research
aspects regarding tooth regeneration and
it's supporting tissues including
periodontium and more generally cranial
facial bone he also plays a key role in
developing innovative micro-ct
methodology and imaging strategy prior
to joining EA 2496 he gained expertise
in bone biology and physiology
completing postdoctoral fellowships at
the university of alberta edmonton
canada and the university of arlene's
france professor Rochefort holds a PhD
in biology and physiology completing his
thesis on vascular tissue engineering
using stem cells dr. Rosen hello
everyone it's a pleasure for me to talk
to you today on this webcast from their
default and I will talk to you today
about from a prayer clinical application
that we are developing in the lab using
the calcaneal kinetics of micro seiki
raging systems any disk slide this
website you can see some example of that
kind of applications yeah we are in
dental school faculty so we do some
stuff on the tools but also we do some
lot of work on the house and using some
contrast agents and we will have a look
on a lot of beautiful engaging about
that kind of work and also we have a
wrap on soft tissue and
like for Chris it's on land and i will
talk a little bit on that so you you all
know maybe the properties of the divide
the come to basics device in the lab
here we have an ethics device the device
is managed in the lab biology simony and
you may know that this device has a lot
of wonderful interesting prodigy from
for extending the first is the free
biscotti murder with it mode you can you
can easily place the animals inside a
pet inside the device and you can easily
imperfectly position the animals where
you want to have the good resolution in
HR cell so it's quite interesting to
have that that kind of mode and it's
very fast really interesting the second
is also the the possibility for a
tenured device to to work with small
animals like mine of course but rats and
maybe also some small rabbits so we are
for that different Bell dedicated bed
and they are all compatible with
anesthesia so we can do some
longitudinal analyses and it's quite
interesting to that kind of of mold
because we can reduce the number of
animals and refine our project on that
the device has the possibility to have I
engaging less than 20 seconds for
disasters imagine devices imagine life
and usually in the lab we use it at
three minutes so good compromise between
resolution time and side of doing agent
with that kind of image we can do
between 10 and
fifteen animals hour hour so it's quite
good and what is also a wonderful is the
ice kid and a little bit of the device
the tricky processing is really fast so
you can easily have the answer of hit a
good image or that in a shoe reaction
with you the scan on that and within
less than one unit we have the answer so
it's quite interesting so we we do a lot
of different project with whatever to
the data and the first of them is the
possibility to do some for work and for
example in the lab module amigo se has
mice line a killing rush line for for
Jen called ml3 this chain is coding for
a protein code name ending up to 3 and
this protein involved in the
inflammasome and in her projections did
to know if there is a link between this
protein and the physiological bone
modeling and modeling so for that we do
a lot of scam on animals and we we do a
lot of analysis on the trabecular bone
at the TBL boom at the proximal lettuce
in this area and you can see here on the
side that there is a huge difference
between male and female in the kale but
also in the white type animals so we we
do that kind of scan and we do also a
follow up during a 16 vehicle and you
can see here the different results for
the bone characteristics for the BB TV
but also the for the claim number and
thickness you can see that the k1 goes
I left a robotic sanitizer and this
phenotype is more severe in the female
kill and compared to the mail kill at
the trabecular bone little we also do
that kind of attendees at the alveolar
bone here and the mandible the alveolar
bone is under the model number one and
Milan number two and you have the
picture of the poem I got out going for
the main in the female in the kill that
also in the Y tagged animals and when we
look at the results we can't see any
difference so no difference between all
the animals all the cables just the
white I've also lame this is female so
and in this animal slide the device oral
health will answer the question whether
very very any difference between the
mice k oh my and the white mice at the
collarbone versus the fabric level
another application in the lab using the
device is that the soft tissue here the
lung and we had the opportunity and
we'll have to work on a far to kill
transgenic mice these mines are
developing fetuses opinion are miserable
day since a kid with a pulmonary
hypertension and with the device we were
able to calculate the lung volume in the
white I passes the kale and we were able
to also quantified the free produce
inside the lamb and in the keio animals
this volume this fiber optic volume was
really increased versus the the
wild-type and the functional respiratory
capacity in the kill animals well lower
compared to the
wild-type animals we also treat these
animals the scale animals with an
antibody and evaluate the effect a
beauty body anywhere we go to trillium
that this antibody want able to rescue
the KO phenotype that is to say that
after the treatment the k1 most of our
kind of normal lung tissue with normal
functional inspiratory capacity so in
that webs is now published in pnas this
year it was really interesting work
another application using that device
here is a lot of folks from Asia hi miss
Audrina generally has done a very
wonderful work using contrast agents and
he was was really involving that because
we have done a lot of can to to see the
full body vessels in life as you can see
in the bottom of the river slide when we
play with them with the threshold on the
world body reconstruction we can see
available body but also use soft tissue
the hot issue and also all the
vasculature have done also kind of
magnification and and the top of this
slide we can see reckon striction around
models and you can see the network the
vessels network the desk area network
inside but also outside the demanders so
he has done that kind of work we ended
with a valium sulphate and you can see
that with with this compound with this
pageant we can
do some wonderful imaging of the vessels
the vascular network at the head but
also at the hip level inside and outside
bones so sometimes quite interesting to
the information of the vasculature
inside brawn and with this compound it's
good still he to albenza unfortunately
this compound is a little so that means
that we cannot do eleanor fitted in on
for a kid with his control so Jeremy try
to find some non-lethal elgin and he has
done a wonderful work on on several
agents to find the best them here you
have some major at the hulk and learn
level and when he used only packed he
was a bowl of course to see the escalade
show the best kadam network around the
heart inside the heart and the lamb but
the vessels were bigger than expected
because of extra leather satchel so he
also has done this work with exia at a
dose of five microliters gram of animals
the image were better that and there
were noisy and we when we increased the
dose at ten microliters to a gram of
animal it was really better but
unfortunately it was little for the
animals so he also done that will create
exit 180 minus and with this action he
can easily see all the dust catcher with
accurate files and shape the same things
was wrong with the liver and the same
vessels with the same conclusion was
itself so Israel excitation with me take
a kind of noisy shape with a glia at
five micro later a better rendering with
agria at ten microliters but also little
m x 800 ones will be better and we also
have done that at the kill a and the
same the same thing was observed you can
see with exit 0 minus that at the kingly
level we can observe a wonderful
vascular network and this was not
exactly the same and with the other
compound so for for this free tissue an
area x-info mallu could be the best at
last your soul I've done the job at the
old facial area and also the design
withers was was really observed so maybe
the extra man could be the best to use
when we want to to to have any follow-up
with animals that also agree ahir
especially at this area at the owners of
an area when we use it at the
concentration what those at five
microliters program and so another
application of that kind of vascular
contrast agent was well done by a PhD
student in another challenger on Conan
his a dentist and she has done a lot of
flags on a falcon Jerry so in dentistry
when we have a perp injury the treatment
is among didn't equipment that means
that the petition has to and as to
remove
the top inside the tooth so you remove
everything that is people in the truth
and after that the tooth is dead so that
future treatment wants to play with that
and wants to preserve the tooth deep
ality and to do that it can do some
tissue engineering using a pulp tissue
and within a stem cells or cowering as
expert stem cells from the tooth this
stem cells as a kind of little key most
cancers property that means that they
have I proliferation I plasticity
regenerative potential also do the stem
cells were extracted by accounting she
put them in collagen matrix put
everything in the toothless line preach
it or not by Epicure and by surgery and
in front everything in the back of a
mouse and after three weeks she wanted
to lose is the the site was buried amid
the cells inside design inside the this
life so for that she sells I've done
some echography and you can see some
image of that in red or in yellow you
are the vessels and you have a larger
number of the falls when the cells were
kicking hypoxia compared to the normal
chocolate itself needs visions were
confirmed by a text can be in case I'll
k5 is targeting narrow and junie disease
so she'll so I've done the same with
city and of course she use the the
contractor junk developed by shiny to
confirm that and you can see on that
kind of picture that there is a huge in
in the hypoxic protected tooth like
compared to the normal click create life
so we have the device with the micro
City and the vascular contrast agents
she was able to to see that epoxidized
on working confusion exists in our
project and with these results Allah
published in stem cells Translational
Medicine this year of course she has
done a lot of continuation of all that a
lot of in- chemistry and so on and here
you have any control of acting email or
chemistry confirm that there is an
increased by Pacquiao of the number of
the source inside the tooth slide
another application done by PhD student
in the lab collection II it's about also
bottle caps themselves but from r at the
time and she he has done critical size
defect at the calvaria level in in the
rack and you put themselves inside
collagen matrix and inside the defects
and he wanted to know over the time if
the cells help the bone regeneration so
using the device we variable with m22
evidence that the metrics with the cells
were able to promote bone generation
compared to to the metrics with
ourselves or compared to without matrix
and that was a ball using the device and
using a longitudinal follow-up in the
VAT the same results but in the louse
I've been gone by so a PhD student and
not go clean you're here so in life it's
quite not the same timing and here we
have to wait over three months to have a
kind of bone regeneration but
she was able to see exactly the same
events that is to say that when we use
cells the bone regeneration is much
better than without cells for were to
conclude about all data when we when we
build the device we are able to do a lot
of imaging text evil but also in vivo
and it's really important to do a lot of
in vivo imaging and the follow-up is
really interesting with that kind of
device because we can really reduce the
number of animals we can really reduce
the n refine our protocol and we can
really increase the understanding of our
project to finish I'd like really to
thank all the people here and maybe I
forgot a lot of people really i want you
to think i'm also packing in there for
promoting with this webcast and also lab
roots for everything thank you thank you
dr. Rochefort before we get started on
the question and answer session i would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can our
first question is for crisp Chris you
mentioned some research that focuses on
radiation effects on the lung during
cancer therapy could you speak a little
bit about the importance of minimizing
CT dose in those longitudinal studies
sure absolutely so one of the things
that we wanted to do primarily was to be
able to follow along an animal that was
dosed with
radiation into one of its longest versus
help you along on on the other side we
have an instrument here at for Mia culpa
start which is basically a surgically
targeted radiation in there so that
you're able to actually just target one
long versus both with rotation but the
most important thing for us was we did
not want to affect any of the the
physiological health of the animal going
forward and we wanted to take images as
many times as possible going forward to
see how there was changes in the lung
function in the lung health one of the
great things about the micro CT the
corner of facts that we use is it
actually has a really really low dose of
verification so as an example for some
of the images that we took with the
lungs they usually were dose for each
image around like 15 mil agree so you're
able and one of the one of our things
that we we put into our protocols is we
would never go over a full grey of
accumulated radiation goes for the
animal so it allows us to do many many
different images over a longer period of
time so it's very important to
minimalistic sedo's any of longitudinal
study so you can get more images to
lengthen out your ability to do a long
term research study on an animal such as
Thank You Gail you mind commenting on
the importance of minimizing CT dose and
longitudinal studies also yeah sure yeah
of course it's really important to have
to to monitor the dose for each scan but
also giving the longitudinal study and
with with the device we have a kind of
facts approximately those for each scan
so
usually we use the trim minute can and
it's around 1000 milligram so we can
really a monitor each scan with X
animals and also during the time and
it's really important to have that kind
of thing in mind for for the animal chef
sure this question is for Gail and Chris
could you comment on the use of contrast
agents in your models are you utilizing
clinical or preclinical agents and are
there specific models when you see the
real advantage of using so for me from
exploit Gail we use a preclinical agents
from limb or most of them are not
clinical legends I think I'm not allowed
to be used in human also so we use it
only in the pretty clinical manner I I
would agree with Gail up for the most
part a lot of the things that we are
using our free clinic such as the extra
challenge nano gold nanoparticles which
we use for vascular study we also do use
omnipage which is a clinical contrast
agent and that is you for there's a
multitude of uses for it in the animal
it's fast to clear that most of them are
it's very good at going through the
kidney because that's basically if
they're so fast it's really not useful
for much else but actually what we found
is if we dos as an example where we
found we were having issues with
hemorrhagic society's life and not going
into the image those animals if we dosed
intraperitoneally with omni bake you're
actually able to use it as a negative
contrast sort of like an opposite of how
you in normally see the opposite of how
it would be used an IV setting
where we would be much brighter than the
issues and you're able to then look at
the issues at a darker threshold so
that's one of the things you so we kind
of use both preclinical in clinic I
agree yes dr. Rushford did you say that
the dose of five UL g of x er 160 XL
contrast is non-lethal so using that
kind of product and the recommended done
at pfizer it's nonlethal so no problem
with with the animals that the contract
it really poor and a lot of noise it
would serve the rounded as also even if
the dose in the book tools the Devon
during is not funny here so that's why
we we try to increase the dose at a 10
and a 10 unfortunately in the compound
is the code for the anyone's right shape
and Chris Gayle have either of you used
this agent any comment on that I
personally have not used the excited
that I exi 160 excellent very good and
concerning strat imaging did you try
osmium text text wrong side as contrast
agent ex vivo we can be no yes so in we
actually here at Columbia we haven't
used osmium tetroxide for fat imaging
we've used it for bone imaging actually
does the fat within the bone the only
time that we actually never really run
into any issues being able to measure
the visceral and subcutaneous fat that's
actually a fairly straightforward fresh
holding with the quantum effects macro
succeeded
a very good contrast with that so
there's certain thresholds that we've
already established that happen with our
SOC spear that you just do a whole body
image of the animal and we're able to
threshold out and fall out the focus of
keeping its nutritional facts early
without adding a user contract Chris
this question is for you why use a
single slice when you can do full 3d
yeah conical beam CT right that's I
would say that's probably the hardest
part about doing as having a CT using CT
as a imaging technology is actually the
analysis right the imaging is pretty
straightforward it's the analysis
afterwards I would say that's probably
because there's a in the ability of a
Thursday when the kinks you do one of
the things that we were looking to do is
to limit the amount of time somebody has
to sit in front of the computer for a
single animal so if we were to do a
whole body image and we would have to
wall out basically a large number of
surrounding choose to make sure that the
thresholds didn't expand into some
issues that might be a budding against
as a spinal muscle or the abdominal wall
so one of the thing and it's also why
they do it in humans is to be able to
just get from that one slice it's fairly
easy to just wall out those areas and
image or and get the coronation of from
a seamless life versus mean many
hundreds of slides the slices that
actually exists with the CC because so
highly highs in the high resolution
there's such a high amount of light so I
would say that the reason is is
expediency when you're doing 60 mikes at
a time that would be an inordinate
amount of time spent on a single mouse
to do the entire body like that and this
is kind of one of the reasons that we
went forward to do this was also saved
but and analysis that didn't need to be
and this question again is for both of
you could you talk a little about
cardiac respiratory dating for lung
imaging for example for measuring lung
air volume measurements oh yes for
foreign lang energy but also for the
heart imaging we use that kind of
kicking and the device able to analyze
the tear flag doesn't and able to
extract the colic to the diastolic a
movement of the heart but also the
movement of the chest and with that we
do not do not have any noise in the 3d
rendering so any time we have to work on
living animals and only part of the body
we have to do that kind of divisive
right scale explained it perfectly when
we're looking at the lungs specifically
to do air volume within the loan you
need to make sure that you date for the
respirations and in some cases we want
to get very high resolution cardiac
dating the nice thing about the quantum
effects that we have here is it has both
cardiac and respiratory gating it's very
simple it extends the image time just a
little bit because it actually does its
light in a way but it actually is really
excellent with gating for the movement
of the breath and those are that's all
the time we have for today I would like
to once again thank Chris Thomas and dr.
Gayle Rochefort for their presentations
I would also like to thank our sponsor
perkinelmer for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through februari 24 2010 you
will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time
I